got a lot of hospitals inside agents
they're holding dr. candle understaffed
we need those personnel back of the base
so we can get the medicine functional
well hold here to cover your back then
will escort the medical personnel when
you retrieve them
they're engaging with the cleaners if
you passed me to the security system I
might be able to find candles location
patched in let's see what I can find can
you see the CCTV feed looks like handle
and her staff are being forced to treat
their wounded that's the only reason
they're still alive
there's a lot of these guys but if you
use cover you should be able to pick
them off without making yourself a
target
we were right here
kill you
additional hostile detected
don't you worry done
prom Adam cover
you
additional hostiles detected
the knee
Oh
morning additional hostel has detected
Billy's
Oh
candolyn our staff are still upstairs
stashed in the kitchen at Kobey's
happy
keep your heads down and keep it quiet
morning hostiles detected
I got no problem
fine
the escort parties taking heavy fire
from the roof they can't move until you
get up there and take down that gunner
we're pinned down no way we'll make it
across alive unless so if you get up
there let's take out the big guns all
yours agent
alpha escort we have an agent on the
roof this candle made it to your
position affirmative here is def just
arrived as soon as the hot dog on the
roof of God will get across safely
98
morning additional husbands incoming
blah blah
mama
you
dr. medic safely across candle and all
staff accounted for no casualties we're
off to a good start agents wish I could
have had your back out there but I think
we make a hell of a team anyway when you
get back to the base we'll talk to
candle and we'll see what she can do for
us
don't be taking unnecessary risks